sure can you see it
yep perfect so the second
talk is about pre-processing in
microsoft solving uh
actually so we haven't talked about this
yet but so i also started to
work on some uh max atta using some
microsoft instances and trying to solve
them efficiently
and your sofa was actually by far the
fastest one
on the instances that i i created and
i'm i'm pretty sure so this is low umbra
the sulphur by jeremias and i'm pretty
sure it is because of pre-processing
and there are the formulas actually have
a lot of kind of
redundancy in there and they came from
somewhere
and so i think i'm i also expect that
that
pre-processing will also be become very
big in microsoft
and uh jeremias is kind of the the top
researcher in this direction
and i am looking very very forward to
your talk
thanks for watching and thank you
everyone for being here
i said i'm going to be talking about
pre-processing in macset
and this will cover work done during my
phd
and to some extent also afterwards
and work i've done with matthias
and marcus levo
so first some general motivation
regarding maxat
in mexico we're sort of following in the
trail of set solving
and seeing these improvements huge
improvements in solver technology over
the last years which has also led
to more and more applications from
excellent so for those if there's anyone
who doesn't know max that just
simply refers to the optimization
version of set
you could say so you're trying to find
assignments that satisfy as many clauses
as possible
or as many or as high much of the
summer weights of positive as possible
so
here's a sort of word plot done by ruben
martins on the submissions entries in
google's color
and every year we see more and more
domains submit benchmarks to the
evaluations so max out is really a
sort of blooming area
and as i mentioned this can also be seen
in solver technology getting better and
better
here's a sort of inverted cactus plot
where you want to be as high up as
possible
you've got different timeouts on the
y-axis and the number of instances on
the
x-axis and we see
the winners from the past 10 maxi
evaluations
run on the benchmarks from last year
using the same hardware
and we can see that the winner in 2010
sold approximately 200 instances
and the winner last year sold 400 over
400 instances
so that's around 81 more instances sold
in about in 10 years
and in addition to solver technology
itself and that's always getting better
i would argue that much of this
improvement is also due to more and more
solvers making use of different kinds of
pre-processing
and the motivations for why you would
want to use previous thing max that are
very similar to what we heard
i mean say you when you encode your
problems
as cnn you might end up with lots of
redundancies
and you want to use sort of automatic
techniques for removing these
redundancies and making your formula
easier
for a maxset solver to solve
here's an experiment we did a few years
ago on the all of the benchmarks
used in the evaluation here we got
the number of variables and clauses
on the right variables on the left of a
non-pre-processed instance on the y-axis
and then the pre-processed instance on
the x-axis
and we can clearly see that
pre-processing in most cases can
significantly
decrease both the number of variables
and the number of clauses
that appear in these instances and
there's a very good reason for this the
one exception might be this sort of part
here where we have some more variables
and i'll get to why why this is during
my talk
so here's kind of the outline of what i
want to talk about
i'll start with some very simple
definitions to make sure
that we're all on the same page then
i'll talk first about
maxwell pre-processing in practice what
what kind of problems do you run into
when you want to use your predecessor on
a
together with your max at solver and how
how you how can you how you can solve
them
and then depending on how long that
takes and how many questions there are
i'll also touch a bit about max that
previous thing in theory
what we know and and what kinds of
interesting research directions there
are
there are to be there and then end
with some conclu with some concluding
remarks
so here's the sort of the basic
definitions just to get us all
on the same page in macset we're giving
a cnf formula
which can be seen as a set of clauses
and then
we're looking for a truth assignment tau
that
satisfies as many clauses as possible
of the of the formula so you want to
maximize the number of satisfied clauses
this is called sort of non-partial or
non-partial max set or maxset and it's
often the formulation that you see in
theoretical computer science and theory
papers
but for solving real world problems and
industrial
applications the stuff i'm interested in
this is not very feasible
instead what you want to do is you want
to work with something called partial
max set
where we are instead given two cnn
formulas
the so-called hot car clauses and that's
all called
called soft clauses and then now we're
looking for a
model a model of the heart process
that satisfies as many of the soft
clauses as possible
so you can think of this like the heart
process defining your your set of
feasible solutions
and then the soft causes defining some
kind of optimization criterion
that you're trying to optimize over and
for simplicity i'll be sticking with
partial mech set
unweighted partial max that in this talk
but i'll say here that you can also have
weights on the soft closest and
everything i'm going to
talk about is directly applicable that
case as well
if you have weights then you're trying
to maximize the sum of weights of
subclasses that are satisfied
so this is the sort of only example i'll
be working with so i'll spend a bit time
here because i'll
get back to this here we have four heart
clauses
and three soft clauses and an example of
an optimal model
sets x1 and x2 to false and y and z to
true
it satisfies all of your all of the
heart clauses
and leaves one soft clause falsified
so it has we say that it has cost one
and you don't need to remember the
instance but you can remember that the
optimal solu
an optimal solution to this instance has
cost one
and still before getting into the sort
of meat of the talk
i'll set up my own context a bit
very roughly speaking maxat solving can
be divided into
two sort of areas we have the so-called
branch and bound max at solvers
that have been shown to be effective on
smaller
hard and often randomly general
generated instances
but as i already said i like to work
with sort of industrial applications and
real world world problems
and over there the sort of dominating
way of solving access are the so-called
set-based max algorithms which
make extensive use of cdcl set solvers
and different ways of reducing max ad
into a sequence of satisfiability
queries
and similarly the field of max
pre-processing can roughly be divided
into
two areas you got pre-processing
techniques
based on the so-called max at resolution
rule that is a
an extension of the resolution rule that
benjamin talked about
max ads and rules based on magnet
resolution are often used in these
branch and bound solvers and then
the thing i worked on during my phd and
what i'll be talking about here
is what i call set-based pre-processing
in macset
and here we want to lift these nice and
effective pre-processing rules from set
to max set
and in the first part here i'll be
talking about
why that is hard and what you can do to
make it easier are there any questions
at this point
doesn't seem to be no yeah there's no
nothing in the wick
so we can just move on so
the motivation here is well since this
sat place max
solvers make extensive use of set
solvers
and as we heard pre-processing is
central
in that solving it's a very natural
question to ask
can we use the nice work being done in
set pre-processing
to solve max set better
and here's my a lot less
my sketch of the pipeline that we want
to achieve that is
a lot less nice than the one vietnamese
had but just to
recap the thing we're aiming at
is a pipeline where we start with an
instance f
and then we run different kinds of
pre-processing techniques
to obtain a pre-processed instance
then we solve the pre-processed instance
and find a model for it uh i'll say here
that in maxsat we usually
assume that there exists models so the
case where the hard clauses are on that
is not that interesting so i'll mostly
just be assuming that there always
exists some model
and then we reconstruct we
take the model for the pre-processed
instance and then we
obtain a solution to the original
instance there are sort of standard
algorithms you can use for this
and the first fairly simple observation
to make
is that this does not work directly from
access
so here we have the same instance as
before
and if we now run for example bounded
variable elimination just freely
on this instance it's fairly easy to
show that you can eliminate
all of your clauses both hard and soft
and now this this instance is trivial
for a set solver
it can give you give you any any
assignment it wants to
it can for example give you this one and
on the side of the pre-preset instance
this assignment that says
x1 and x2 the true and the other ones to
false it doesn't falsify any of the soft
clauses
because there are no to falsify so it
has cost zero
but if we now try to reconstruct this
we get the same instance back and
actually we're falsifying two
two of the soft clauses so this
assignment has cost two
and earlier we saw an assignment that
had cost one
so this is not optimal so we had an
optimal
assignment for the pre-processed
instance but then when we try to
reconstruct
we get something that's not optimal
so directly applying these techniques
it's not sound from excellent
and one but one possible way of making
it sound or fixing this problem
well okay so as we heard benjamin say
the problem is essentially that
pre-processing preserves satisfiability
it does not preserve the cost of models
or in some cases not even the same one
and how do we fix this well there was a
paper from bello
at all in 2013 that proposed the use of
so-called labels
these labels have many names but i'll
stick but
they can also be called assumption
variables or reification variables or
blocking variables depending on
in which context you're working
and the idea is that we start with a max
that instance having the heart process
and the soft process and we add this add
this label variable
to each soft clause so we take a new
variable
denote by lfc and extend
each soft clause with this label
variable
and now we can run a set-based
preprocessor
on the union of the clauses of the heart
clauses and these extended soft clauses
and the only thing we can have to
restrict to that solver that
preprocessor from doing
is resolving on these labels so you can
do anything
except resolve on these label variables
and then you run it for as long as you
want to either to fix point or not
and output whatever clauses remain
and then you say these are my new hard
passes
so whatever remains after pre-processing
are the hard pauses
and as soft process you take a unit
negation
of each of the label variables that you
added in the first step
and now you call your max ad solver
on this instance and you obtain a
an optimal solution to this
pre-processed instance
and now you can run the same standard
set reconstruction algorithms
to obtain an optimal solution to the
original instance that you started with
so here also we can go back
let's go back to the example one last
time i already mentioned this
labels this i'm not sure i quite like
the term i'll use it here because of the
that's what they used in the first paper
but you can think of them as relaxation
variables or blocking variables
so now the same instance one last time
we start by taking we have three soft
clauses so we take three label variables
and add them
to our soft clauses
and now we run a set preprocessor
and tell it to not resolve on these
variables
and when it reaches fixed point it might
what remains are these clauses so we got
two
two hard clauses remaining after
pre-processing
and then we take a new soft clause for
each of the three labels
that be that we added in the first step
now when we solve this this max add
instance
we get an assignment like this that sets
l1 and l2
to false and l3 to true
and if we now run a the standard set
reconstruction algorithm
on this model and then ignore the label
variables
we see that we get back exactly the
optimal solution that we had in the
first step
so this is what we did i think it was
among the first papers in my my
thesis and the thing we observed was
that it doesn't work
so here's the so the quote unquote
normal cactus plot
and that line here you want to be as far
to the right as possible
and the line in the middle here uh is
our own implementation of an
offense so called implicit hitting set
based algorithm for max ad
and if we if we run pre-processing in
the way i just described
what we get is this green line over here
so we actually end up
solving less instances and doing worse
but luckily there's a fairly simple
solution
that fixes this problem i'll not go into
too much detail
but as long as you tell your max ad
solver
to use the labels as as assumptions
some access solvers add a lot of
assumption variables to control soft
clauses
so instead of adding the unit negation
of a label as a soft boss
you use that label as an assumption
directly
and then you end up with performance
corresponding to this yellow line over
here
and it's a fairly simple trick and
nowadays most of the max out solvers
that i'm aware of
do this but the point i want to get
across is that
doing this is not required for the
correctness of a max algorithm
so if you just take any max ad solver
that you don't know of and you try to
use pre-processing
in a black box manner you might end up
just worsening performance
by accident even if
reusing labels as assumptions would fix
that
and while this fixes the first problem
we most more recently we've looked at
what happens the intermediate solutions
found during that solving and we see
that there's still
other issues to be solved when it comes
to integrating method solving and max of
pre-processing the plots over here
show the difference between the
cost of a non-optimal solution obtained
during search
as computed on the pre-processed side
and on the original instance side
so to say that in another way what we
did was that we took every solution
found by a solver and then we ran the
reconstruction algorithm on that
solution
and then we compared the cost of the re
constructed solution
with the original solution we see that
there's actually quite a big discurrency
the the cost of the pre-processed
um the cost of the solution to the
pre-processed instance can sometimes be
three times higher than it actually can
be believed to be
three times higher than it actually is
and this is a problem because many
effective implementations of maxwell
algorithms make use of these
intermediate solutions to obtain bounds
on the cost any solution it can be an
upper bound
on your cost so if your solver thinks
that it has a solution that's
three times worse than it actually is
then the heuristics
that build on these bounds are not going
to be as effective
and in the paper i side here we we've
uh proposed a solution to this in the co
in the context
context of local search max set notable
search for max sat
but doing fixing this in an effective
way for these other
types of max of solvers is still an
interesting future
research direction
and then i'll end this part of the talk
by saying that in addition to these sort
of
liftings of common set techniques
nowadays many solvers incorporate
various heuristics
that they don't call pre-processing but
that in practice are pretty much like
max
are our max at specific pre-processing
techniques
uh many of the so-called core guided
solvers use stratification and hardening
where you use the bones you have on your
optimal cost
to deduce that some of the soft losses
need to be satisfied so you can harden
them
if your soft class is too expensive to
be falsified then you can just harden it
in the field of implicit heating set
solving there was a paper on how you can
use these reduced costs
which are a common technique in mixed
integer programming
and you can sort of transfer information
you learn from them
to max that to again fix soft process
true or false and there are
some other techniques also which
consider for example partitionings of
clauses to make solving easier
but in contrast to sort of at least my
understanding of that pre-processing
the field of max approved processing is
a bit divided
so these are heuristics that are bound
to specific solvers and there's not
and unifying the theory underlying all
of this could be very interesting
in the future
so here's the take-home message from
this part and it is that pre-processing
can be very effective in macset
as long as you make sure that your
solver supports it
so black box integration between a max
of pre-processor and a method solver
has a there's a very good chance that
that won't be effective but if you do
some
careful integration between the two you
you'll often end up
winning as you're doing that sorry
any questions at this point the second
part is shorter
so i i'm just curious about you know you
know max out you're kind of stepping on
the territory of uh very close to ilp
yes in my opinion what to do what can we
learn from them what can we teach
the ilp people and what can they teach
us about this
it is a good good question
the reduced cost fixing is one example
of something that
they taught us
other than that it could be interesting
to i've some
i've thought a bit about these cuts that
are commonly used in ilp
and if you could somehow use them
in that there doesn't seem to be a clear
way of doing it
because because mixed integer
programming is a bit more expressive
than clauses
but for sure i'm sure you could do
something
but i'm not aware of too much work in
there yet
thank you
okay so then i'll underestimate my time
talking about sort of the theory
underlying
max reprocessing and the
only definition i'll be using is that of
a core or an mus
we say that a set of soft clauses
is a core if it's unset together with
the heart clauses
and an mus if it's subset minimal so no
subset
of the set is a core
and i'll denote the set of all musl of
an instance like this
and why is this relevant for max hat
well it's fairly easy to see
that every solution to max that instance
needs to falsify at least one clause
from each mus
so already in the first paper proposing
this label based framework
they showed that if you pre-process an
instance using this
techniques that vietnamese also talked
about from set solving bond variable
elimination etc
you and obtain another instance then the
pre-preset instance will have the same
musss
as the first instance you started with
and in my phd we took this result and
showed that it implies that the best
case number of iterations
that means sets over calls required to
solve
the pre-processed instance will be same
will be the same as
the original instance so an informal way
of saying this is that
set-based pre-processing with these
techniques for maxed
can only sort of speed up your
individual sets over calls
it cannot decrease the number of sets
over calls that you need
at least not in the best case
your mia so there are two kind of
questions regarding some explanation so
is it so a question is it relative to
find which clause
uh causes insults
yeah it depends on your application but
often
if you have a if you find an optimal
model
and you know it's optimal then finding
which clauses are on that
is trivial you just check the models
check all the clauses against the model
so so it's usually quite
easy if i understand the question
correctly
and also the question whether you need
to find one
maximal solution of all of them
[Music]
typically you work in cases where you
just
want one optimal solution but
there's nothing stopping you from it if
you want to have more of them there is
some work on enumerating
enumerating max of solutions in the same
way as there's work on enumerating
set models so and the way you do that is
pretty much the same
you add add an extra clause that says
that you need you want to get something
else
and then you keep going so you can do
both
okay but doing pretty uh good point here
is of course that doing pre-processing
and model enumeration
is unclear this is how i'm
not sure how that will work
and so for pre-processing i'm mostly
concentrating on the situation where we
want one
so there's one option
okay thank you okay
so after my pfd we sort of generalized
this result
a bit uh i'll not i will not go into
details here but
a few a few years ago we proposed this
extension of
so-called resolvent asymmetric tautology
is to make that
with the rat clauses are what you can
use in set solving as basis
for as a sort of theoretical foundation
for many of the techniques that
benjamin talked about and we showed
that you can have this concept of a red
clause from access where basic uh in for
an informal way of saying the definition
for those of you familiar with responses
is that a clause is
has read in the max that sense if it has
read
in the sad sense on a non-label variable
and we also showed that if you know if
you use a pre
any kind of preprocessing technique
which can be seen as the addition and
removal of these
red clauses then you won't affect the
set of mbss
and this this is a fairly general result
because
most of the techniques that benjamin
mentioned and i
i'm not sure about hyperbinary
resolution but the other ones can be
seen
as addition and removal of these drag
forces so
this is a very general general way of
showing that
most techniques that you leave from stat
solving won't affect
your messes and again
won't affect the best case number of
iterations that are required by sat
solvers either
so the take-home message for this part
is that
significantly altering the execution of
max out solvers
requires techniques that are able to
alter your muss's
and the liftings of these commonly used
techniques inside solving do not do this
however again
there are these heuristics that have
been proposed as part
of solvers that actually can change your
muscles
the hardening that we talked about the
real cost fixing and
a technique of my own calls which we
call subsumed label elimination
they can fix soft process that are parts
of muss's
to to true uh to
harden them so suppose them to be
satisfied
and then there's also this technique
that they the authors call for intrinsic
at most
one constraints that can actually alter
the muses of the formula
and that actually has been shown to be
very effective implemented in the maxed
solver called rc2
so in my view a very interesting
future research direction here would be
to
sort of trying to unify all of these
existing uh
techniques under one theory and see what
could come out of that
and these these pr clauses that were
mentioned in the discussion after shot
solving
i think there could be some interesting
connections to be made there
sort of generalizing that or extending
that to max that as well
so i'm pretty much almost out of time
i'll
sum up so pre-processing as it was
actually so it can be from
that can also be very effective for max
set
but you need to be very careful on how
you combine
your solver with your pre-processor and
currently
the field is a bit divided with lots of
solver writers
developing these very nice heuristics
for their solver
that heuristics that could be used in
other solvers as well
but usually then and tend to end up not
being used because they're just part of
the solar code
instead of a separate pre-processor
and if you want to try this um we have a
max
set pre-processor called macbrey
and then there's also another one that
i'm aware of called co-processor
by norbert that i believe are
pretty freely available on the online
uh and if you want to learn more about
maxat
fahim has given a talk in this seminar
not this seminar but at the time
institute
and we gave another one with mate a few
weeks ago
and now this is already i did not know
that the second hand
second uh volume of the handbook is
already published but there's a chapter
on max that's
over there as well
and that's pretty much all i wanted to
talk to you about if you
have any questions i'll have i'll happy
to take them otherwise i thank you all
for your
attention
thanks for your nice talk um other
questions maybe
let me start with a question so uh what
about
in processing for microsoft
that's another very interesting
direction uh
for these core guided solvers for
example the difficult
part is the fact that the cardinality
comes now i'm getting a bit more
technical but
the cardinality constraints that they
add are often very
sort of tight they're not i've sometimes
played around with what pre-processing
could do to those and it does not seem
if you pre-process your instance
and then you try to do just on the
closet added by the method solver you
often end up not doing anything else
but if you could effectively use the
learning clauses of this ad solver
you could maybe do better i've done some
very preliminary tests but
i haven't been able to make it work
effectively
okay looking forward to follow up on
that
uh armin you have a question yeah yeah
so
um you of course i mentioned this
already so there's this
pr clauses and of course we even defined
like in general what redundancy mean
what's your take on this do you think
these pr classes or even maybe the
semantic
uh redundancy would give you something
could it not be the case that the dms is
still even for semantic redundancy would
stay the same
yeah what did you say in the end what
would they design
so you have the mosses right they would
not change
processing okay
uh no you can one of the techniques
that the one i mentioned subsumed label
elimination can be
seen as a type of pr class so
you can change time yes with process i'm
very sure of this so so the real
question is where the
line is right like you want to have a
maximum definition of what
what keeps the mos is okay i see thanks
so um are there any other questions
otherwise let me uh i i have maybe one
more kind of
a high level or because um
uh do you know how many more instances
of percentage-wise would you solve
by turning off pre-processing kind of in
your software do you are you wearing
in the competition or the competition
results
how big of a that's a good question
[Music]
i mean the solver that you mentioned in
the beginning is incomplete so
you wanna there is more about how fast
can you solve them
for complete solver solvers
um i don't have any like hard
numbers but my intuition is that
you mostly win on how fast you solve
them if you have a
timeout of say two hours
then then usually usually most of the
mexican instances all
are either sold faster than that or not
at all
so pre-processing mostly decreases the
amount of time you spend solving
and not yet too much on there like
does not yet increase the number of
instances solved by
too much okay
yeah no i cannot yeah yeah no also let's
take this also further offline because i
also have some follow-up questions
because more of my of my specific
instances where it is um
uh where i think it's i can see that
that's been very useful because these
require very long runs right and that's
yeah
well yeah that could be if you have
really hard instances then the situation
changes again
and you have long runs then you go of
course
welcome thanks again um
and so the now we go to the the last
talk in the session which will be by
uh martina uh so uh